اذا ما هو حال حقوق المراه في ايران بعد
مضي نحو مئه وثلاثه ايام على الاحتجاجات
التي انطلقت في سبتمبر الماضي على خلفيه
مقتل مهسا اميني بعد اعتقالها في طهران
قال نائب العام الايراني محمد جعفر منتظري
ان الرد النهائي على شكوى عائله امين لم
يعلن حتى الان وجاء في التصريحات التي
نقلها الاعلام الايراني عن النائب العام
للبلاد ان اسره امين يتقدمت بشكوى ضد
المجلس الطبي لكن سبق واعلن محام والدينا
سامينيني ان اولياء الدم احتجوا على قرار
هيئه الطب الشرعيه امين البالغه من العمر
22 عاما اعتقلت اثناء زياره مع اسرتها الى
العاصمه الايرانيه طهران من قبل دوريه
شرطه اداب في طهران بحجه ارتداء حجاب غير
مكتمل وبعد اغمائها في مركز الشرطه نقلت
الى المستشفى
ليعلنا بعد ثلاثه ايام عن وفاتها هناك
ولتشعل وفاتها المدن الايرانيه غضبا من
القمع المنهج ضد المراه واليوم افاد موقع
ايران انترنال بان عمال شركه بتروكيماويات
في مدينه عبدان جنوب غرب ايران اضربوا عن
العمل بعد تلقيهم رسائل تهديدا بسبب
مشاركتهم فاحتجاجات امينه منظمه حقوقيه
اعلنت ان الاحتجاجات تسببت في سقوط عشرات
القتل والجرحى في مناطق متفرقه في ايران
منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر وسطهامات للشرطه
بالتعامل بوحشيه مع المحتجين
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
الى الافراج غير المشروط عن جميع من تم
سجنهم في ايران بسبب ممارسه حريتهم بشكل
سلمي بحسب بتعبيره
بعد طرد طهران من لجنه المراه في الامم
المتحده في وقت سابق هذا الشهر واضاف
المتحدث ان الكفاح من اجل حصولياء ايران
على حقوقهن مستمر واقعوا حقوق الانسان في
ايران ليس افضل حالا من واقع الاقتصاد
وانهيار العمله وتراجع القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين الذين عن توفير المواد الاساسيه
بسبب الغلاء وارتفاع الاسعار
[موسيقى]